c'est une société qui est là pour faire
uniquement du profit de la rentabilité
c'est tout le reste est secondaire se
dire qu'on est con fait de l'empathie
quand on s'occupe des personnes âgées ce
sont les salariés qui s'occupent des
personnes jose e sur le terrain bien sûr
que oui vous prenez une aide soignante
elle entre 7 et 10 minutes le matin pour
faire une toilette quand je prends ma
douche matin le coup de rasoir un coup
de brosse à dents bon au niveau
shampoing jeux pas trop de problèmes
d'ouïe
j'en ai pour à 15 20 minutes cela une
personne âgée qui est importante qui est
sûr en liquette allongé il faut
l'apprendre faut la tourner il ya des
gestes techniques à faire et des gestes
et mimiques aux affaires c'est hyper
compliqué entre 7 et 10 minutes tout ça
pour faire de la rentabilité c'est une
salariée une aide soignante pour dix
résidents or vous donner des exemples de
la toile est ce que vous avez d'autres
exemples à nous donner sur le quotidien
en tant que résidents qu'aux rayons sur
le quotidien on en parlait avec avec
guillaume une personne âgée sur une
journée de 24 heures elle a deux heures
et quelques de présence humaine à côté
d'elle si avec ça déjà c'est inconscient
c'est un constat qui est incroyable la
nuit vous avez 2 à 3 personnes dont
souvent s'il n'y a pas des ja pas
d'infirmières dans les maisons de
retraite 1 la nuit ya pas de faire un
programme sans personnel alors c'est
quoi il ya deux aides soignantes par
exemple à partir de 110 2 3 % résident à
notes et vont se reposer avant de manger
un morceau fumer une cigarette il n'y a
plus que deux personnes qui errent dans
les étages et dont il ya il faut savoir
aussi que les les personnes âgées ils
ont une difficulté
entre le jour entre la nuit on a des
personnes qui ont des pathologies
particulières notamment alzheimer qui
peuvent déambuler dans les couloirs si
vous êtes le deuxième étage quelle
personne de 1 me au 4ème étage on fait
comment on peut pas le savoir alors donc
elle n'arrête pas de courir c'est c'est
totalement c'est un boulot de fou quoi
c'est un signal des exemples comme ça
ils sont à trois puisque c'est vrai que
trois personnes pour 100 résidents dans
la nuit c'est vrai qu'on voit on dit on
sait que les personnes âgées à se
réveille souvent dans la nuit peut y
avoir des accidents on peut avoir des
chutes est-ce que vous avez déjà vu vous
un truc et enfin où vous a raconté un
truc qui s'est passé une personne âgée
qui est resté peut-être partir toute la
nuit parce qu'il est personne je sais
pas ce qu'on entend des choses
incroyables
oui au niveau des choses incroyables
malheureusement ça fait quand même des
années qu'on apprend par les articles de
presse régionaux des des choses un peu
oui horrible j'ai pas d'autres mots
c'est horrible parce qu'effectivement il
ya des choses où on peut avoir des
homicides entre résidents sous manque de
surveillance non
oui donc ça effectivement c'est des
choses qu'on connaît depuis assez
longtemps quand même malheureusement
dans le secteur on le dénonce nous à la
cgt depuis très longtemps
au niveau du groupe orpea on vient de
voir qu effectivement au delà d'un
problème effectivement de maltraitance
on se rend compte qu'il ya un système
mafieux mais là il est très clair c'est
poser aujourd'hui on vient d'avoir
perquisition sur le groupe perquisitions
sur les directions régionales donc
effectivement on se rend compte que
malheureusement dans ce secteur
d'activité les opérateurs sont pas aussi
bienveillant qu'ils le font croire je
maintiens à dire à tout le monde quand
vous regardez les cinq plus gros
opérateur dans les épaves lucrative vous
regardez les fondateurs de ces groupes
ils font tous partie des 500 plus
grosses fortunes de france
je vous parle d'un secteur qui a entre
25 et 30 ans maximum
je vous parle d'un secteur qui est
appuyée sur de l'argent public